a Christmas carol in three-dimensions ok
so just FYI I might talk about the plot
a little more than usual when reviewing
this one however to be fair if you don't
know the plot of arguably the most
beloved holiday classic of all time then
this movie is probably about you you
humbug bastard
ok so I've seen a lot of renditions of A
Christmas Carol some great some good
some just ok it's safe to say that the
Christmas carol is probably my favorite
holiday story and since you're wondering
my favorite version so far is probably
Bill Murray Scrooged I don't know how to
do any more I'll get back to you on that
but for my money George see Scott owned
the role of Scrooge but it seems that
there's a new version of a Christmas
carol that comes out every year in the
form of some made-for-tv movie so it was
really cool to see the Charles Dickens
classic brought back to the big screen
and it's easy to jump right into because
the plot is exactly how it's always been
bitter old Ebony or Scrooge hates
Christmas people and pretty much
everything except money Chilton's is
Chilton's
so on Christmas Eve his dead partner
Jacob Marley comes to him and says yeah
you pretty much need to change your life
so you don't end up like me so let's put
it this way Scrooge um you ever seen
this show scared-straight
yeah we're gonna do that to you well
technically speaking three ghosts are
gonna do that to you but you have a good
one tonight buddy have fun peace and so
that night he's visited by the ghost of
Christmas past present and future to
show him the errors of his past how
they've led to his sad state in the
present how he's affecting the people
around him and what will happen if he
doesn't change his ways a lesson I'm
sure we'd all be so lucky to have for
the most part I like their take on the
spirits but Christmas past is kind of
funny though Christmas present and
Christmas feature are pretty much the
same in anything you're ever gonna see
them in ever the Christmas past changes
every time between version to version he
or she is either really happy and
playful like a child or straight up a
creepy messed out elvish manchild
version of the Human Torch
yep in this version we get that second
one
honestly this ghost reminded me of that
creepy serial killer vibe co-worker that
everyone knows at least one of in the
workplace if he got high on opiates one
day and lit his head on fire and talks
like the candy Mountain unicorns from
Charlie the Unicorn
but after that we get the ghost of
Christmas present present has always
been my favorite
he's crazy eccentric absent-minded he's
jolly kind of like Santa in that nitrous
oxide kind of way just like the
president he's chaotic unpredictable and
very short-lived and after he and
screwed to see that most people have
Scrooge knows thinks he's an absolute
douche in the present Scrooge moves on
to the ghost of Christmas future who is
straight up the Grim Reaper but maybe
the nazgûl from Lord of the Rings on
account of the black horses of death but
the beady red eyes --as he has in this
version which ultimately just serve as a
chase sequence in this rendition of the
story which he now brings me two things
that I thought were cool in this version
but kind of long-winded I don't know
maybe I'm just a purist when it comes to
this story but there are sequences like
the ring wraiths horses chasing screws
that I thought looked cool in 3d and
it's clearly made for 3d it's a total 3d
showcase but I just thought they were a
little unnecessary now granted the
story's been done a zillion times before
so you got to throw something new in the
mix but for me I thought the 3d was new
enough like in this chase sequence for
example I remember thinking to myself
okay this is cool this looks cool but
after a few minutes you start thinking
to yourself alright now you're clearly
cutting into precious dialogue time and
also with Christmas present at the point
where he's like alright let's go grab my
robe and as remember it taking a really
long time from the moment Scrooge
grabbed his robe to when they actually
arrived at their destination again I
really like the effect they did for them
traveling I just thought it took a
really long time and if you like a
Christmas carol for the dialogue these
3d showcase scenes might just seem a
little long and winded for you Christmas
past was okay when they traveled it was
meant just to show off the 3d but it
seemed really fast and just really cool
so it didn't bother me I'm just ill
trying to find the intended metaphor and
having an old man flying with a flaming
opiate meth-head oh it's a code but what
brought it home for me was this one
scene that I don't remember seeing in
any other rendition of a Christmas Carol
but maybe it's out there I don't
remember seeing it though and it's a
scene where bob cratchit comes face to
face with Scrooge and Cratchit can't see
him and Scrooge knows it but Cratchit
looks up and he makes eye contact with
Scrooge but it was just so convicting
for Scrooge he just saw it that scene
was badass that Bravo to that scene in
the end I thought a Christmas carol was
a great rendition of a classic
Christmas stories starring Jim Carrey
unlike something else the 3d was great
and the story definitely lives on to
make this feel like Christmas is upon us
once again yeah so what I have a soft
spot for those movies that pull them at
holiday heartstrings but if you are
officially done with Halloween you're
ready to start feeling like Christmas is
right around the corner then this movie
is a must so go see a Christmas carol
you'll be glad you did